so we can't get away from holding and
should we tell him to leave that he's
ruining our honeymoon oh we can't that
would crush him and he's already so
crushed wait I got it we kill Holmes oh
no that was crazy for a multitude of
reasons we have a bunch of fun
activities planned if we include him
it'll cheer him up and he'll leave right
but hurt most of our activities kind of
geared towards couples in one couples
activity that wouldn't be more fun with
your boss there
welcome to sensual food tasty the art of
feeding your lover I feel like I don't
belong here I love the way the mud
revitalizes your skin and I love how it
masks my shame I am loving this this is
actually quite pleasant you know when
you invited me to join you today I was
skeptical I had been sitting by the pool
contentedly watching a bee he struggled
to avoid drowning and thinking to myself
how I am like that bee and I hope it
survived we can't afford to lose any
more bees they didn't
the point is I'm glad you invited me
into your frivolous activities you
helped me to remember there's more to
life than the NYPD Wow
that's great to hear sorry I feel a lot
better I think I may be heading home
unless you need a third for tonight's
activities sensual pottery I think we're
good he's leaving
I planned work we saved our own
honeymoon and fun bonus we cheered up
holt
okay it's time to celebrate you know
what that means this bee needs a seein
her a oh my god this baby needs a
coconut nerds oh I thought you were
saying this music oh my god
that's my reaction all right I'll go get
us a couple coconut
you